öffentlichen Dienst veröffentlichen
Arbeitgebern arbeiten insgesamt 6,3
Millionen Menschen und von daher sind
die Tarifverträge des öffentlichen
Dienstes eine der Leitwährungen für die
Lohnentwicklung in diesem Land anders
als in vergangenen Jahren haben wir als
Gewerkschaften deshalb kein breites
Paket mit mehreren Forderungen heute
beschlossen sondern es geht um
Einkommenssicherung
unsere Forderung konkret wir wollen im
Rahmen eines mindestbetrages und
monatlich 500 Euro für alle
Beschäftigten die Einkommen sichern das
steht im Zentrum der dann beginnenden
Tarifrunde verwenden das mit einer
Forderung nach einer linearenerhöhung
von 10,5%
die Auszubildenden fordern wir eine
Erhöhung der Ausbildungsvergütungen und
200 Euro und wir fordern weiterhin die
Vorführung der tarifvertraglichen
Regelungen zu Übernahme von auszubilden
uns ist wichtig dass es eine Zeit und
inhaltsgleiche Übertragung bis dann zu
findenden Tarifergebnis auf die
Beamtinnen und Beamten gibt und wir
haben die Erwartung an die öffentlichen
Arbeitgeber dass sie die Regelungen zur
Altersteilzeit mit uns verlängern
wir fordern für eine Laufzeit von 12
Monaten das machen wir immer aber ich
will sagen in Zeiten ökonomischer
Unsicherheit ist es umso wichtiger mit
berechenbaren Zeiträumen in der
Tarifpolitik zu arbeiten und sie wissen
dass wir als Verdi in diesem Jahr ja
eine Reihe von Tarifabschlüssen getätigt
haben auch mal 24 Monate zum Beispiel
für die Beschäftigten in den
Hafenbetrieben dann aber ausdrücklich
mit einem Sonderkündigungsrecht um auf
etwaige Entwicklungen bei der
Preissteigerung zu reagieren deshalb
ganz klar unsere Forderung nach einer
Laufzeit und 12 Monaten wir haben heute
noch immer das Tarifergebnis aus dem
Frühjahr nicht umgesetzt das liegt daran
dass die kommunalen Arbeitgeber das
Massiv verzögern bis heute ist noch
keine Zahlung geleistet dazu kommt der
Druck der ja nicht weniger geworden ist
jetzt in der Situation das ganze Thema
der
medizinischen Flüchtlinge es wird den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aufs Auge
gedrückt ohne das mehr Personal gestellt
wird also wir haben im Gegenteil noch
noch weiter verschärfte Situation in den
Kitas was dazu führt dass da eine
extreme Bereitschaft ist wir hatten
jetzt in Vorbereitung auch dieser
Diskussion mehrere Videokonferenzen die
größte Beteiligung aus dem kommunalen
Bereich kam aus den Kitas mit einer ganz
hohen also auch Bereitschaft sich hier
einzusetzen für Ihre Belange also wir
machen uns an der Stelle überhaupt keine
Sorgen